[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID ARMITAGE:
Thanks to everyone
for coming this morning.
It's a great opportunity
to talk about the book
and remember 10 years ago,
this was an idea that found me
rather than an idea that
I was looking for myself.
I was working out in Southern
California at the Huntington
Library, just in
Pasadena, in 2006-2007.
You may remember if
you cast your mind back
all those years, that was at
the height of the violence
during the Iraq War after
the US-led invasion.
At that moment, and I'll come
back to this in a few minutes,
there was a highly
political debate
about what to call the
conflict in Iraq at that point,
whether it was an insurgency
or terrorism, or indeed,
civil war, and I was listening
to that debate on TV and radio
at that point.
At the same moment that
I was reading some papers
in the Huntington Library from
the 19th century in the middle
of the US Civil
War by a man called
Francis Lieber, whose name may
not spark many associations
for most of you, but
he is truly important,
because he produced the first
codification of the laws of war
in the middle of
the US Civil War
that became the basis of the
Hague Conventions and Geneva
Conventions later on.
And as I was listening to this
very tense debate about what
to call the war in Iraq, I was
reading his letters where he
was having exactly the same
problem about what to call
the violence in North America--
in the United States--
in 1862, 1863.
Was it an insurrection?
Was it a rebellion?
Was it a civil war?
What was a civil war?
He was having real
trouble sorting that out,
and I thought, OK.
Here are two data points,
one from the 1860s,
one from the early
2000s, about struggles
over the meaning of civil
war and its application
to ongoing real-time
conflicts, and at that
point I was searching
for a new project
and I thought,
OK, it's found me.
I don't want to
write about this,
but I have to write about this.
And as often happens
with historical projects,
they take much longer
than you think.
So fast forward 10 years
later, and a little bit more
than that, I finally
finished the book
with a whole series
of other civil wars
up to and including Syria, and
Yemen, and the present now.
So what I want to do now
in the next half hour
or so is just lead you
back through history--
through my history.
The book, "Civil Wars:
A History in Ideas"
that I ended up
writing about this,
and it was one of these stories
that took me back 2,000 years.
I wasn't expecting it to
have to go back that far,
but this often happens
with historical projects.
You want to find out
what came before.
What was the origin?
What was the
beginning of the thing
that you're writing about?
And that's why it took
10 years to go back
2,000 years in about 250 pages.
So strap on your seat belts.
It's got to be a
fast ride, but I
hope will get us all the
way up to the present
from ancient Rome
and give you a chance
to ask some questions about
why this history might matter.
Why knowing this
history might matter
to think about the present.
So let me start, again,
a few years back.
Many of us can remember a
moment not very long ago when
history was supposed to end.
In the years after
1989, we were told
by people like Francis
Fukuyama, the free market
was going to supplant
every other form
of economic organization
around the world.
Its affinity with
democracy was going
to ensure that all
other forms of politics
succumb to its advance.
Globalization was
going to create
a borderless world of
unlimited prosperity
and unassailable human rights.
Progress would reach
its consummation
in a utopia of perpetual
peace of the kind hoped
for by Immanuel Kant in the
late 18th century-- seems
like a very long time ago now.
As we all know, just
over a year ago,
history bit back and
with a vengeance.
It turns out history
was just drawing breath
before springing back
into action with ever more
unsettling energy.
Protectionism, of
course, seems to be
returning to slam
globalization into reverse.
The alliance between
liberalism and democracy,
which we've depended on
for almost a century,
seems to be coming apart at
the seams around the world
in the US and elsewhere.
And the world is still obviously
not a very peaceful place.
Indeed, it's a
very violent place.
States, for the moment at
least, are mostly at peace
with each other, but
after 1989 at least,
wars within the states have
become the most widespread,
the most destructive, and
we might even say, therefore
the most characteristic form
of organized human violence
around the world.
Of the nearly 50 wars now in
progress around the globe,
from Afghanistan to Yemen,
there were only two conflicts
in 2016, the last year for
which we have reliable figures.
Only two conflicts
in 2016, which
took place between two states.
In this case, one between
India and Pakistan
and the other between
Eritrea and Ethiopia.
Don't worry if you don't
remember either of those.
They were both relatively
small border disputes.
The one between Eritrea and
Ethiopia lasted only two days.
All the rest of the wars going
on around the world in 2015,
2016, 2017, and now 2018,
started within the boundaries
of a single state.
Far from what my
colleague Steven
Pinker has called "The
Better Angels of Our Nature,"
"Winning the War on War," what
we have now is a moment where
what's been called a long
peace among states now
stands under a
very dark shadow--
the shadow of civil war.
The global estimate of battle
deaths in civil war since 1945
is over 25 million people.
That is about half the
estimated direct casualties
in the Second World War.
Even that count doesn't
include civilians, the wounded,
the displaced, all those who
die from the knock-on effects
of civil war, such as
disease and malnutrition.
Even if we look beyond the
human toll of civil war,
devastating though that's
been, to its material
and economic costs, the impact
has been no less appalling.
Think of the more than 500,000
Syrians killed in that country
since 2011.
Over more than half of
that country's population,
civil war has displaced
internally and externally.
Civil wars cost lives--
a great many lives,
but they also
waste resources, divert spending
from welfare to warfare,
disrupt economies, often
for decades, foment crime
and disease, suppressive
productivity,
and have these long-term
consequences which
send civil war-torn countries
backwards on every development
index.
Not surprisingly,
development economists
have actually called civil
war "development in reverse"
for reason.
The annual price
tag for civil wars
has been estimated at
about $123 billion a year,
which is roughly the equivalent
of the amount the global north
budgets for economic aid to
the global south each year.
Civil war has long been
thought the most destructive
of all kinds of human conflict.
Some raw numbers
could illustrate this.
If we take all the way
back to ancient Rome,
where we'll return
in a few minutes,
at the height of Rome's civil
wars in the first century BCE,
perhaps a quarter of all
Rome's male citizens age
between 17 and 46 were in
arms during those conflicts.
1,700 years later, probably
a greater proportion
of England's population
died during the civil wars
of the mid-17th century
than would later
perish in the First World War.
Two centuries later still,
the combined death toll
from both sides in
the US Civil War
was vastly larger relative
to the size of the population
at the time than the casualty
rate in the Second World War.
The estimated number-- it's now
about 750,000 from both North
and South in the US Civil War--
would be equivalent to
about 7.5 million deaths
among the present-day
American population.
Slaughter on a scale like
this scythed through families,
shattered communities,
but also shaped
nations and scarred imaginations
for centuries to come.
However, I think we should
be cautious about assuming
that civil war is
an inevitable, even
necessary part, of our makeup.
A feature, not a bug in the
software that makes us human.
Some people have assumed that
we are inherently conflictual
and that civil war will
continue perpetually.
Not perpetual peace,
but perpetual civil war.
That assumption, I think,
dooms us to suffer civil war ad
infinitum.
To unsettle the notion that we
are condemned to interminable
civil war, in my recent
book, "Civil Wars: A History
in Ideas," I've tried to
bring historical tools to bear
on the challenge of civil war.
I argue that it's neither
eternal nor inexplicable.
It has a history with a very
identifiable beginning, if not
yet quite a discernible end.
What humans have invented,
they may yet dismantle.
What's been created through
an effort of intellectual will
may be demolished
by a similar effort
of imaginative determination.
At least, that's one of
the messages of the book.
This book is, I believe,
the first long-range history
of civil wars from their
beginnings in Republican
Rome in the first century
BCE all the way up
to the present in South
Asia and the Middle East.
Over 2,000 years, as
it were, from Sulla,
the Roman general here on the
left, to Syria in the present.
My goal in the book
is to point out
the significance of
civil war in forming
the ways we think
about the world,
and especially about politics.
I argue that despite
its destructiveness,
civil war has been throughout
history conceptually
generative.
Without the challenges
posed by civil war,
I argue our conceptions
of politics, authority,
revolution, international
law, humanitarianism,
and globalization,
to name just a few,
would have been quite different.
Perhaps even in some
fundamental sense, poorer.
The experience of
civil war, the efforts
to understand it, to mediorate
it, even to prevent it,
continues to inform our ideas
of community, authority,
and sovereignty to this day.
For those of us
lucky enough to live
under the shadow
of the long peace,
civil war is now more a
matter of memory and metaphor
than lived experience.
However, it's seeping
into political language
and has been for some time
in the US and elsewhere.
For example, just
to go back, again,
a few years, in
2004 then-Speaker
of the US House of
Representatives, Newt Gingrich,
described American politics
as if it were a civil war.
These are his words
at that point.
"The left at its core
understands in a way
that Grant understood
after Shiloh.
That this is a civil war.
That only one side will
prevail and the other side
will be relegated to history."
He then sketched out
the terms of the fight.
"This war has to be fought
with the scale and duration
and savagery that is
only true of civil wars.
While we are lucky in
this country-- in the US--
that our civil wars are
fought at the ballot box,
not on the battlefields,
nonetheless, it
is a civil war."
These words seem
almost prophetic now,
of course, in terms of
the political strategies
of both parties, especially
the Republican Party
and the ramping up
of violent language--
the language of violence and
the incitement of violence
that we've seen over the
past couple of years.
Political polarization,
of course,
as many have documented, has
accelerated and deepened,
and the violence of
political language
has sharpened along with that.
One could cite
many, many examples.
This is just a
particularly graphic one
from the battle for the
Republican nomination in 2016,
but I could give you 100
other headlines using
this language of
civil war, and you
can see it throughout our
political discourse now.
There's even been a slew of
articles in recent months,
especially after the
inauguration a year ago--
the presidential inauguration
a year ago-- asking,
is the US heading for
another civil war?
That may be going too far, but
we should be very concerned
about this polarization,
and I think
we should also be
concerned about the ramping
up of that language and what
it might portend about--
precisely this language
of victory and violence,
ineluctable enmity that
Gingrich and others have been
fomenting for many years now.
In statements like these
about civil war in the US--
but I can also document this
from France, from Britain,
from Latin America
in recent months--
one might say that democratic
politics seems increasingly
to be coming civil
war by other means.
Civil wars are therefore
everywhere now in the headlines
and on the ground,
in hearts and minds,
and in commemorations
of civil wars past,
and in contemporary
debates, such as those
about removing
Confederate statues
from around the country.
As the Vietnamese
writer Viet Thanh
Nguyen has recently written,
"All wars are fought twice.
The first time on
the battlefield,
the second time in memory."
And I think that's especially
true of civil wars.
Some countries
imagine themselves
to have been free of civil war.
Others can hardly
imagine themselves
without the memory of civil
war-- the US, of course,
among them.
And the international
community perceives still
other countries--
Iraq, for example-- as
a perpetual battleground
of unending civil wars.
In each case, there
seems little doubt
among those using
the term "civil war"
about what is and
is not a civil war.
Everybody knows it when
they see, it we might say.
But I think the benefit
of some history,
and perhaps the curse of
remembering that history,
is the knowledge that
civil war has never
been quite as stable or
transparent a category
as its use in popular
speech might imply.
Now I argue in the book that
more than most other forms
of conflict, civil wars spring
from deep and deadly divisions,
but that they at
the same time expose
identities and commonalities.
To call a war civil is to
acknowledge the familiarity
of the enemies as members
of the same community--
not foreigners, but
fellow citizens.
And I talk in the
book, for example,
about some of the
myths about civil war.
Think of Cain and Abel
in the Hebrew Bible,
or Romulus and Remus here.
In Roman myth,
civil wars are often
cast as wars within the family--
wars between brothers
like the conflict
between Romulus and Remus at the
founding of Rome, for instance.
This commonality at
the heart of enmity
is key to understanding
why civil war captures
the imagination, but also
why it's so terrifying.
"Civil war has something
atrocious about it,"
remarked the German
legal thinker
Carl Schmitt in the 1930s.
"It's fraternal war
because it is conducted
within a common political unity,
and because both warring sides
at the same time absolutely
affirm and absolutely deny
that common unity.
That I think is one basic source
of our horror about civil wars,
and we shouldn't underestimate
the effect of them enforcing
a recognition of commonality
amid confrontation
of making us see ourselves
in the mirror of enmity."
Civil war, I argue, has been
paradoxically fertile in part
because there's never been a
time when its definition was
settled to everyone's
satisfaction
or when the term could be used
without question or contention.
This is in part because it's
been disputed and debated
within so many different
historical contexts,
and I tried to reconstruct
many of those from Ancient Rome
up to the present
in the book itself,
and I'll give you a couple
of concrete examples
in a few minutes.
Naming, we might say,
is a form of framing.
The application of
the term "civil war"
can depend upon whether you're
a ruler or a rebel, the victor
or the vanquished, an
established government
or an interested outside party.
The battle over names
often continues long
after the conflict has ceased.
So even now in some parts
of the US, of course,
if you talk about the
Civil War rather than
say "the war
between the states,"
you can get in trouble
over that and there
are more serious examples, for
example, in contemporary Italy.
To talk about the struggle
between the Italian resistance
and the fascist
government between--
and World War II as a civil war
is still very controversial,
because it implies a
kind of moral equivalence
between the two sides.
Yet how can we tell
civil wars apart
from other kinds of
conflict-- other kinds
of wars, when so many
internal conflicts spill
over that country's
borders, like that in Syria,
or draw incompetence
from outside
as happened in Liberia
and Rwanda in the 1990s,
or in places like Iraq and
Afghanistan more recently.
Can such wars even be considered
civil in the sense of taking
place among members of the same
community, when for example,
insurgent groups comprise
transnational elements like
Al-Qaeda, or Daesh, ISIS--
or deliberately set themselves
against the existing world
order of states by
proclaiming their wish to form
supranational communities,
like the caliphate
proclaimed by ISIS.
Is every civil war
really a specimen
of the same species when
so many distinct dynamics,
ethnic conflicts,
wars of secession
and national liberation, battles
for succession and so on,
can be found across history
and around the world, all
being called civil wars or
thought of as civil wars?
But when local
context may make it
impossible to analyze
specific incidents of violence
as part of larger patterns
of collective action, what
in short is civil war?
I argue in the book that
civil war has multiple pasts.
Historians like me can
show the paths not taken,
as well as the many and
winding roads by which we
came to the present.
I call my own version of
this history "A History
in Ideas," investigating a
key idea or family of ideas
in Western and ultimately
global political arguments
in their multiple
historical contexts--
again, from Ancient Rome to the
modern Middle East and South
Asia.
In the course of the book, I
identify three major turning
points in arguments over
the meanings of civil war
across those centuries.
The first in the late 18th
century came at just the moment
when contemporaries needed
to distinguish civil war
from another category of violent
and transformative upheaval--
revolution.
And I have a chapter mostly
about the American Revolution,
or as it was called at the
time, the American Civil War.
The first usage of that term
American Civil War I found
is in 1774, 1775.
So not in the 1860s,
but in the 1770s.
The second turning point I
identify is in the mid-19th
century, and this occurred when
the first attempts were being
made to pin down the meaning of
civil war in legal vocabulary--
an effort made
not coincidentally
during the conflict we know as
the American Civil War of 1861
to '65, and this is
where Francis Lieber, who
I mentioned a moment ago,
comes into the picture.
The third turning point
comes during the late phases
of the Cold War, when
social scientists
decided to define the
term to help them analyze
the conflicts going
on around the world
during their proxy
wars and decolonization
in the 1960s and 1970s, when
it was necessary to distinguish
civil wars from
anti-imperial conflicts,
from other forms of
collective violence
in that period of turbulence.
Our confusions about the
meaning and the application
of civil wars to
contemporary conflicts
are the product, I argue, of
the concepts long and contested
and winding history.
Only with the help of history--
the tools of historian,
I argue, can we understand
just why its meaning remains
so controversial today,
and I'll come in conclusion
to two examples
from Iraq and Syria
about that contestation over
the meanings of the term itself.
At least until the 19th century
and the great historical
watershed marked by
the American Civil War,
civil wars were understood as
cumulative historical phenomena
whose sequence gave
a shape, albeit a far
from comforting
shape, to the past,
and whose avoidance
might turn out
to be one of the
achievements of the future.
Civil war was
often an experience
refracted through the prisms
of history and memory,
through the record
of past civil wars,
in distant times and far-flung
places, and out of fears
that the civil wars
in one's own country's
history might indeed
repeat themselves.
Victims of civil war have often
experienced it through history,
and historical
approach is therefore
a particularly appropriate
way to study its impact
and its imagery over time.
Conflict over its
meaning, as well as
the meaning of conflict itself,
are prime subjects, I argue,
for historical treatment.
To tell my story,
I break the book
into three parts,
each of two chapters.
The first part,
"Roads from Rome,"
traces changing conceptions
of civil war chronologically
from the first century
BCE to the fifth century
of the common era.
During that period, I argue,
Roman conceptions decisively
shaped arguments
about civil war--
about its normative
and legal definition,
about how to recognize a civil
war when it was going on,
about where it came from, about
whether it was likely to recur,
and what could be
done to prevent it.
"All roads lead from
Rome," I argue in the book,
and there's a controversial
part of the book where
I decide not to
start with Greece,
and [INAUDIBLE] we could
talk about that afterwards,
but I make a strong
argument that it
was the Romans who invented
civil war, not the Greeks.
The Romans knew that the Greeks
had a conception of conflict,
which was very different from
their conception of civil war,
and even Greek-speaking
authors at the time
knew there was a difference
between their conceptions
of conflict as well.
Civil war, I argue,
was not a fact
of nature waiting
to be discovered.
It was an artifact
of human culture
that had to be
invented, and I argue,
the invention of civil war is
only a little over 2,000 years
old, and it can be dated back
to the first century BCE.
The first people to
understand their acts
of collective violence as both
civil and war were the Romans.
This was because they understood
their most wrenching conflicts
in definitively political terms,
as conflicts among citizens.
The Latin word for
citizens is "cives."
C-I-V-E-S. The root from
which we get the word "civil"
as well as "civility,"
"civilization," and "civilian,"
and they saw these conflicts
among citizens-- among "cives"
and civil conflicts as
rising to the level of war,
rather than being riots,
rebellions, or seditions,
for instance.
What's peculiar
about the way Romans
thought about war is they
named their conflicts
by the enemy they were fighting
rather than the place where
the war was fought,
so they talked
about a civil war
in the same way
that they talked about, say, a
war against the African leader
Jugurtha as the Jugurthine War.
We often talk about
wars as the places
where they take place--
the Pacific War.
Even the World
Wars, we might say
are defined according to
their place-- the Vietnam War.
We don't tend to talk about
them as in terms of enemies.
At least, we don't
talk about the Iraq War
as the Suddamic War.
That would be the Roman way of
talking about that conflict,
for instance.
The Romans adopted
this idea of civil war
very reluctantly at first.
For a long time, they used
it only with trepidation,
and it still takes, I think, a
feat of historical imagination
to recall just why civil war
was originally so disturbing
and named only with fear.
We can see this most
graphically in the case
of that famed civil
warrior, Julius Caesar, whom
you can see here in a
19th century rendering.
He narrated his power struggle
with the Roman General Pompey
in an unfinished work
now generally known
as "The Civil War,"
"Caesar's Civil War."
However, that title was
not Caesar's, and he
did all he could to avoid using
the phrase in his own text.
For Caesar, as for
many Romans, civil war
remained the war that
dared not speak its name.
Yet, though it would turn out
to be an enduring and disturbing
strain of Roman
history that suggested
a tight relationship between
civil war and civilization
itself.
Civil wars, the
Romans began to argue,
came back so often across the
history of the Roman Republic
and into the early decades
of the Roman Empire
that they appeared to be
woven into the fabric of Roman
public life.
This created a set of
narratives of a civilization
prone to civil war,
even in some sense
cursed by civil war that
would last for centuries
and inform later
understandings of civil war
across the early modern and
modern periods and beyond.
Indeed, I argue in the book,
that for more than a millennium
and a half, civil
war would be viewed
through Rome-tinted spectacles.
As I show in the second
part of the book,
"Early Modern Crossroads,"
those Roman explanations
and their narratives
provided the repertoire
from which later
thinkers in Europe
between the 16th and
the 18th centuries
drew their own
conceptions of civil war.
Since the Enlightenment
of the 18th century,
two conceptual clusters--
on the one hand civil war,
and the other revolution--
would be tied to each other
but also pulled apart from each
other, rather like this image of
sedition from the 17th century,
With quite distinct moral
and political implications,
civil wars were
increasingly thought
of as backward-looking,
destructive, and regressive,
while revolutions came to be
thought of as future-oriented,
fertile, and progressive.
Successful civil wars, like
the American Revolution,
would be rebranded
as revolutions.
Revolutionaries would
later deny they'd ever
been engaged in civil wars.
We can, I think,
therefore perform
a kind of conjugation-- a
political conjugation here.
I am a revolutionary.
You are a rebel.
They are engaged in a civil war.
The third part of the book,
"Past of the Present,"
traces the conceptual
heritages of Civil War
from the era of the US
Civil War to our own time
in the early 21st century.
I argue again that the 19th
century's great contribution
to the history of
ideas of civil war
was the attempt to
civilize it by bringing it
under the domain of law,
beginning, again as I mentioned
earlier, with the first modern
codification of the Laws of War
by the Prussian, later American,
lawyer and political scientist,
Francis Lieber in
the 1860s, and then
later in the various revisions
to the Geneva Conventions
after the start of
the Second World War.
Civilizing civil war,
as we might call it,
remains a task for the
international legal community
right down to our own time.
The roots of their concerns
and the tension civil wars
have raised within
what we now call
international
humanitarian law are
the subject of the
latter part of the book,
and I'll illustrate
that in just a moment
by talking about the origins
of the use of the term
civil war in relation to
Syria a few years ago.
In this latter part of the
book, I trace developments
as civil war goes global across
the course of the 20th century,
especially in the period
after the Second World War
and into the Cold War.
The boundaries of
the communities--
the thinkable, imaginable
communities within which
civil wars took place,
expanded beyond those
of states and empires
in this period
to encompass the whole
world in a conception
of global civil war found
originally in the early 1960s.
For example, John F. Kennedy,
in his second State of the Union
Address, spoke of
the Cold War itself
as quotes, "A global civil war
that has divided and tormented
mankind."
That expansion of the community
within which civil war could
take place has, I
argue, deep roots
in various strains
of cosmopolitan
thought which had long suggested
that all wars among humans
were, in fact,
civil wars, and this
led to a strain of
pacifism to try and prevent
civil wars taking place
within a common humanity.
Yet that expansion also collided
with the late 20th century
effort, which I mentioned
a moment ago, beginning
in the Cold War by
social scientists
to bring some conceptual clarity
to the study of civil war,
starting in the 1960s.
In that period, in
particular in a project then
at the University
of Michigan called
the "Correlates
of War Project--"
it was necessary to begin to--
not just to codify
but actually to code
particular forms of
conflict, their occurrences,
their recurrences,
the time they took,
their origins, their
causation, in order
to do long-end studies,
Large-end studies of
conflicts around the world
to try and determine some
of their common features.
And it was in the
context of that effort
that the first detailed
definitions of civil war
were produced, which continue
to be used today, not just
by data scientists studying
conflict around the world,
but also are used by
international organizations,
like the World
Bank, for instance
and their determinations
of the boundaries
between different
forms of conflict.
I argue in the book,
teasing out some
of the examples of these usages,
that these early attempts
to define civil war were
in some sense doomed,
because civil war is such
a slippery political and
ideological concept.
The sedimented history of--
conceptual history of
civil war going back
to the Roman Republic,
layered over since then
with these languages of
law and social science,
has given rise to complexity in
our own current understanding
of civil war, which
I'd like to illustrate
just now in conclusion with
those two examples I mentioned
earlier-- one from Iraq where
this book began, and then
the more recent
example from Syria.
After talking about each
of those very briefly,
I'll try and draw together the
threads of this talk and indeed
of my book by giving
a few lessons,
including a little
bit of hope that
might emerge from what otherwise
seems like a rather dark story.
So let's go back to
Iraq just for a second.
At the height of the
violence in Iraq,
in 2006-2007, over
3,000 people a month
were dying in that country.
And as I mentioned before, there
was a vehement disagreement
that the category-- whether
the category of civil war
could in fact be used to fit
the facts on the ground in Iraq.
Representatives of the
George W. Bush administration
at that time and other mostly
right wing military strategists
and political pundits denied
that the turbulence in Iraq
merited the name of civil war.
Perhaps it was terrorism
or insurgency, but not
a civil war, they argued.
For many inside
and outside Iraq,
there could, in fact,
be no doubt what
was happening at that point.
For example, the then U.N.
Secretary General, Kofi Annan,
told the BBC in
late 2006, "When we
had strife in Lebanon
and other places,
we call that a civil war.
What's happening now
in Iraq is much worse."
At the same time, various
sectors of US media
began calling the conflict
in Iraq a civil war.
Adel Ibrahim, a young
Shiite sheik from Iraq
vehemently told the "New
York Times" at that moment,
"You need to let the
world know there's
a civil war here in Iraq.
It's a crushing civil war.
We don't know who our enemy
is and who is our friend."
Quite predictably,
there was adamant
disagreement that
the label "civil war"
did, in fact, fit
the facts in Iraq.
In December 2006, then-Iraqi
Prime Minister Nouri al-Maliki
briskly rejected
characterization
of the conflict as a civil
war and accused Kofi Annan
among others of burnishing
the image of Saddam Hussein
as a viable belligerent.
Various other
commentators, indeed using
the social scientific
definitions of civil war,
went back and forth about
whether it really applied
to what was happening in Iraq.
In one case, two
commentators, including
the very eminent British
military historian, Sir John
Keegan, worked out that since
the middle of the 17th century,
there had in fact been only
five civil wars in the entirety
of human history--
the English Civil War of the
1640s, the American Civil War,
the Russian Civil War,
the Spanish Civil War,
and the Lebanese Civil War.
And in that sense and for
that reason, they argued,
what was happening
in Iraq could not
be described as the
world's sixth civil war.
Instead, they proposed, that
quotes, "The disorders in Iraq
do not constitute a
civil war," but are
nearer to what they termed
a politico-military struggle
for power, whatever that may be.
Now the Iraqi government at
the time and representatives
of the Bush
Administration officially,
formally denied that Iraq
was in the grip of civil war.
To admit that it was might
imply that the government there
had lost its authority,
and it also entailed
a bevy of strategic indications
for the US-led coalition
forces.
If it were a civil war, that
would mean deciding which side,
Sunni or Shiite, for
example, the coalition
should support as it made its
bets on an internal struggle
for dominance.
That was one of the
implications of thinking
of this as civil, internal war.
It could also imply that
the invaders from outside
had unleashed sectarian enmities
that previously had no outlet
and that events were
spinning out of control.
If such instability continued,
then much higher troop levels
would be needed to
prevent it from spilling
over Iraq's borders.
Alternatively, a rapid
but undignified withdrawal
might be necessary to avoid
being drawn ever deeper
into indigenous dilemmas, which
an alien presence would only
inflame but not resolve.
So calling it an
insurgency or terrorism
ramped it down,
turned any attempts
to fight it into police actions,
and threw the responsibility
for those police actions onto
the then-Iraqi Administration,
not onto the coalition forces.
Let's fast-forward just a few
years to the conflict in Syria
in 2011-2012.
Ordinary Syrians in the early
months of the war in Syria
knew very well throughout 2011
and the first half of 2012
that what they were
experiencing with their--
in their contention with
the regime of Bashar
al-Assad was indeed a civil war.
Outside Syria, however,
interested parties
across the globe continue
to debate whether or not it
had descended into civil war.
So for example,
in December 2011,
White House Deputy
Spokesperson [INAUDIBLE]
demurred when asked if he
agreed with a U.N. official
that Syria was experiencing
civil war at that point.
"We think violence needs
to end in Syria," he said,
"and that includes among
opposition elements.
But there's no way to equate
the two, which in my view
is implied by using
the term civil war."
Now of course at that
moment, Assad's regime
saw only rebellion.
The opposition at
that point said
they were engaged in
resistance against him--
even revolution
against him, and powers
like Russia and
the United States
held the threat of a civil
war over each other's heads
as they jousted
over intervention
and nonintervention.
Now importantly
for our purposes,
it took the International
Committee of the Red Cross
until July 2012--
more than a year into
the conflict in Syria
and after as many as 17,000
people had already died--
to confirm that what was taking
place in Syria was in fact
a civil war, or to use the
technical language of the Red
Cross and of other
international organizations,
now the official term
is "armed conflict not
of an international
character," or N-I-A-C--
NIAC, which is the
official legal term
from international humanitarian
law for a civil war.
Only when the Red Cross had made
that determination in July 2012
would it be possible
for the relevant parties
to be covered by the specific
provisions of the Geneva
Conventions, for instance.
Also for things like
humanitarian aid
to be taken into the country.
The reluctance to
call the conflict
a civil war non-international
armed conflict has,
in fact, become typical of
international organizations
in the 21st century,
because now so much
politically, militarily,
legally, and ethically
hangs on the use or withholding
of the term civil war,
or again, non-international
armed conflict.
In fact, a set of legal
protocols going back
to the Geneva Conventions
and ultimately to Francis
Lieber's codification of the
laws of war in the mid-19th
century--
those legal protocols
were designed
to humanize the
conduct of civil war,
to bring to bear humanitarian
constraints on its practice,
to minimize some of the terrible
human costs of civil conflict,
but they've often served to
constrain international actors
in their attitudes towards
conflicts in countries
like Syria in the present.
Now as these examples of
Iraq and Syria reveal,
there's no agreement at
the moment about just which
features of civil war
should take priority
and its various
definitions, nor is there
any agreement about
the way in which
they might be assigned
normatively or even legally
to specific conflicts.
Being precise in
the sense of using
clear definitions of
civil war turns out
to be inescapably
political and ideological.
The elements of the various
definitions of civil war,
as much as their application
to particular conflicts,
are always matters for
principled dispute,
and this seems to be especially
true in the case of civil war--
an essentially
contested concept,
we might say, about essential
elements of contestation.
Now a philosopher,
a lawyer, perhaps
even a political scientist,
might find only confusion
in these kinds of wranglings
over the term civil war.
However, historians--
a historian like me--
sense an opportunity.
The historians'
task, I think, is not
to come up with a better
definition of civil war
on which all sides could agree.
I think that's a
doomed enterprise
as the history shows,
but instead to ask where
these competing conceptions
came from, what they've meant,
how they arose from
the experience of those
who lived through
civil war, or who
attempted to understand
it in the past
and indeed into the present.
The stakes are now
very high indeed
for applying or withholding
the label "civil war"
to a conflict, and
it's unlikely, I think,
that politics can ever be
eliminated from its definition
or its application.
Like the term "genocide"
with which it's closely
linked the 20th
century, civil war
has not only political
connotations, but also
legal implications that can
trigger concern and action--
even intervention from the
international community.
Over the course of
2,000 years, I argue,
civil war has been subject to
similar disputes and divisions,
and there's never been a time
when its definition was settled
to everyone's satisfaction,
or when it could be used
without question or contention.
Let me just conclude in
the last couple of minutes
with some reflections
on what I think
are the purposes or the
outcomes of this reflection
that I've made in the
book, and then tried
to elaborate a little
of here this morning.
I believe that a long
view of civil war, going
over 2,000 years in
the way that I've done
can encourage three things--
humility, complexity,
and indeed, hope.
Humility first,
because we can see
that much of what we think
we now know about civil wars
was in fact discovered
centuries-- even
in some cases millennia ago.
Social scientists
who study civil war
tell us that civil wars last
longer, recur more often,
and leave deeper wounds than
other kinds of conflict.
However, the Romans
had discovered
all of that during their own
civil wars in the first century
BCE, and in their reflections
over five centuries
of civil war from
the time of Cicero
up to the time of St. Augustine.
Secondly, complexity.
Complexity because
of our struggles
over the meaning and
significance of civil war
arise from multiple and
layered histories that jostle
and collide in the present.
Controversies over the
meaning of civil war
arise from those
multiple histories,
which I believe need to be
carefully excavated, as I've
tried to do in
the book, in order
to properly understand them.
And then finally, hope, or at
least a somewhat tempered hope.
The long view shows
that civil war is not
a congenital curse for humanity,
but an affliction that perhaps
one day we might gradually cure.
The incidence of civil
conflict indeed now
seems to be declining.
Major civil wars, for example,
the Civil War in Sri Lanka
which lasted more than 25 years,
and the Civil War in Colombia,
which lasted even
longer-- over 50 years--
have lately been
terminated after decades
of death and destruction.
At the moment, the
entire Western hemisphere
of the Americas is free of civil
war for almost the first time
in two centuries.
Perhaps we might
see this as a sign
that humanity is at last on
the verge of un-inventing
what the Romans had first
invented over 2,000 years ago.
Until we can un-invent,
un-imagine civil war,
we need history, I believe, and
a very long view of history,
to assess the future prospects
for escaping one of our most
destructive discontents.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Not sure this
is exactly on topic,
but sort of keys off of it--
you know, conflicts of
ideas are part of humanity
and they don't always
lead to armed conflict,
and obviously sometimes
they do, and I think
all of the civil wars that--
whether you call
it that or not--
come down to that, and--
including in this
country over slavery.
Is there any
pattern that you can
say that-- in which
the conflict of ideas
is ultimately going to
lead to armed conflict?
And sometimes I worry
about current-day America.
DAVID ARMITAGE: Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
Yep.
No, it's a very pointed
and timely question.
One of the lessons that I
learned from examining--
earlier examinations
of civil war,
which are always retrospective,
either during the midst
of a conflict, after it's ended,
or when people are afraid it's
going to come back again.
And this is true going all
the way back to the Romans
and you can see it endlessly
repeated all the way
into the 20th century, is the
sense that you never quite know
when a civil war is going to
begin, or when it has begun,
so there's never a formal
declaration of war.
There's rarely a
specific moment when
you can say ah, that's
when the civil war began.
But particularly the
Romans started doing this
and then others followed them in
digging back into the fissures
within society, the ethical
disputes, the poisoned language
which had led to the first
signs, the first glimmerings
of civil war.
And one of the lessons
that came out--
comes out of so many of
those earlier treatments
is it's often language itself
which is the first sign,
even before you have
swords, or you have guns,
or you have any
armed conflict, it's
the eruption of bitterly
divisive language,
the politicization of
commonality into enmity--
the very language of civil war
itself being used in conflict
long before anybody is
actually holding swords
to each other's throats
or pointing guns
at each other's heads.
And that may be one
reason for your anxiety--
my anxiety, as well,
that there has been,
I think, a
discernible ramping up
of that language of civil
war in American politics,
not just referring back
to the US Civil War
as a an image of
what might happen,
but talking about politics
itself is something
which is a fight to the death--
ineluctable enmity,
totally divided sides--
which can have no
communication with each other.
I don't actually think
we're at the point
of open civil war in the sense
of armed conflict, but one--
I'm very disturbed by that
sense that the language
is ramping up.
This has often been
seen for 2,000 years
to be a symptom of division
that leads to civil war,
and when you have that ramping
up of violent language.
And indeed, the
incitement of violence
by some of our politicians
in a country which
has such easy access to so
many weapons, it's inevitable,
I think, or we might fear
that it's inevitable--
will be some conflicts
coming out of this
even if it's not the
kind of armed arrays
that we imagine from the
US Civil War, for instance.
So we should be
very wary and very
careful in our use
of this language,
but also in watching
that language
and seeing where it's
erupting, because it
can be one of the very
first seeds or signs
of incipient conflict of a
much more destructive kind.
AUDIENCE: So following up
on sort of a similar note,
the '60s seemed like
a pretty crazy time,
although I wasn't there.
And I was wondering
if you could maybe
contrast that a little
bit when you're talking
about really divided societies.
And then also sort of
related to that is the--
from what I remember
from my history classes,
the '60s were not
crazy just in the US,
but also in Europe
and elsewhere.
And similarly, not just was
there a civil war in Syria,
but the broader Arab
Spring seemed to be-- all
came about at a time, and
then we're seeing here
with the rise of populism
in Europe and America,
it's sort of in a similar
timescale as the Arab Spring.
I wonder if there's like
global linkage to this.
DAVID ARMITAGE: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, that-- and we could even
pull the focus out further
and say you can go back to
the late 18th century where
there's a wave of
revolutions across the globe,
the middle of the 19th century,
the spring time of nations
in 1848, the period after
the First World War--
Especially with
anti-colonial revolts,
and then coming back
up to the 1960s,
the simultaneity of student
revolt across the world
in 1968, and the
intercommunication among
student groups and other
disaffected groups at that
point, in the context
of decolonisation,
anti-imperial activity
during that period, as well,
and I think it's
not a coincidence,
this language of
global civil war--
it had been used a little bit
at earlier periods in the First
World War and the Second World
War, but it's in the '60s.
That term "global civil war"
really comes to the fore sense
that violence and
division is being
shown not just between
societies, but also
within societies as well.
The liberation movements
which might call themselves
in many cases resistance
or revolutionary movements
were part of exactly those
kinds of larger patterns which
can be thought of as a
global set of fissures
within humanity itself.
And then if we fast-forward
to the era of the Arab Spring,
and then think about the wider
context of non-state actors,
asymmetrical warfare,
global terrorism
surrounding that at the same
time as well, I think again,
it's significant that
language of global civil war
starts coming back 2010, 2011,
2012, to describe civil wars.
It's often used prejudicially
to describe civil wars
taking internal divisions.
For example, with Islam
and spreading them
onto a global scale--
globalizing civil war
within a common humanity
of which those internal debates
or disputes or rebellions
or resistances or revolutions
are just symptoms as well.
So I think you're
absolutely right
about those global
linkages, and again,
from my point of view as
an intellectual historian,
I'm interested in that language
and where it comes back
and what it betokens.
But these things
are rarely isolated.
The idea of a civil
war is something
that's purely internal.
It was barely true
even in Ancient Rome
and certainly hasn't been true
in the 19th and 20th centuries,
where now there's so
much intercommunication,
mutual surveillance, mutual
learning among resistance
movements and
revolutionary movements,
and then also the fears
of those pushing back
against those
movements-- see them
as a kind of many-headed hydra
taking over the globe, as well.
So those imaginations of global
civil war feed off each other
and ramp up again the
divisions and the fears
and conspiracy theories
that come through them, even
though they are indeed
based upon commonalities,
both of resistance
and repression,
and all of those
moments, whether it's
late 18th century,
mid-19th century,
middle of the 20th century,
or the early 21st century,
so there are lots of comparisons
and patterns there for sure.
AUDIENCE: I'd like
to get a better
idea of the consequences of
labeling something a civil war.
I was looking-- just looking
a little bit at the definition
of NIAC, Non-International
Armed Conflict--
DAVID ARMITAGE: Correct, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --which
Is basically seen
as a very plain definition,
and there's also protocol too,
evidently, that states can
sign, of course, saying OK,
so a war between a state and
a responsibly-led armed group.
So my question is
what do you see
as the legal or actual
consequences of labeling
something a civil was as
opposed to something else,
and also maybe speak
to the difference
between the civil
wars and perhaps
an insurrection
rebellion or revolution.
DAVID ARMITAGE: Yeah.
Yeah, and I detail some
of this more in the book.
I won't go into all
of it here, but not
all of the terms of
the Geneva Conventions
apply to conflicts which are not
of an international character,
so there's some slippage
there to decide,
for example, in the
case of the Balkan
Wars in the 1980s
and early 1990s,
the debate was between whether
to call the war in Yugoslavia
a non-international armed
conflict taking place
within the boundaries
of a single state,
and then also the
question, did it
turn into an
international conflict
after say Serbia broke off?
Because that would determine--
that determined at that
point, for example,
which leaders might ultimately
be tried for war crimes, what
kind of intelligence
gathering or information
gathering might take
place during the conflict
itself to be used subsequently
for retrospective prosecutions,
so that boundary between
international and
non-international was
operative in those wars.
In later conflicts,
like Syria for instance,
it has implications first
for the basic question--
is this a police action
by a legitimate regime,
like the Assad regime
and other countries
should stay far away from that?
If it is determined,
as in the case of Syria
by the ICRC that
this is, in fact,
a non-international armed
conflict under Protocol Two
of the Geneva Conventions,
then various other things
kick in, like the ability
to take humanitarian aid in.
Also again to gather information
for potential prosecutions
later on.
So there are those different--
two sets of boundaries.
One between non-international
and international armed
conflicts which determine which
parts of the Geneva Conventions
take place, and then
the broader debate
about whether it's
an armed conflict
in this international
legal sense at all.
If not, if it's an insurrection
or rebellion, for instance--
that's something
which is usually
determined to take place under
the rule of domestic law.
There may be some possibilities
for human rights violations
to be used in later
prosecutions there,
but it's not under the
international humanitarian law,
necessarily so it's--
drawing those boundaries
becomes very important in terms
of what kind of relief
can be brought in,
what sort of
[? posterior ?] political
or military outside powers will
take towards the conflict, what
the legal consequences may be
for those who are prosecuting
it, if at the end
of the conflict
you get war crimes
trials, for instance.
So there's a whole
host of implications
that flow from that, and I think
that determines the reluctance
of organizations
like the ICRC to make
that decision about
whether this is
a non-international
armed conflict,
because from that
will flow a host
of other legal and
political consequences
as well, which have to be taken
into account during the course
of the conflict and also
subsequently as well.
Something that's observable--
I didn't mention this just
because of time, but--
is the way in which
non-international armed
conflicts, civil wars, are
actually becoming more and more
conducted under international
humanitarian law,
because those who might
be thought of by others
as insurgents or rebels are
very keen, for obvious reasons,
to get the recognition of
the international community,
to have the regularization
of warfare itself,
to give them recognition
as legitimate belligerents
within those conflicts.
That gives them a
military and political
and even an ethical advantage
in those conflicts as well.
So we're actually seeing now at
the moment in the 21st century,
greater usage of
international humanitarian law
in civil conflicts than had
been the-- internal conflicts
than had been the case
in inter-state war,
partly for empirical reasons.
Most of the wars
going on are indeed
those non-international
armed conflicts,
but also because there are
greater rewards for competence
to comply with international
humanitarian law
during those conflicts, as well.
It's also the case
that more and more
internal non-international
civil wars are being concluded
by treaties now than any
other form of conflict,
because that provides
a means for negotiating
among the parties, for
clearing up some of the debates
and disputes about conduct
during the conflicts
themselves.
Also for bringing in the
international community
as brokers or arbitrators,
and guarantors
of those international-- those
agreements among the parties
as well.
So in a paradoxical
way, civil war
is on the leading edge of
international humanitarian law
and the civilization of
warfare more generally.
So again, a great
deal hangs not just
for individual
specific conflict,
but also for the
future of conflict
as a whole being
driven by civil war
and the international armed
conflict through its pressures
on international
humanitarian law right now.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for the great questions.
[APPLAUSE]